je vais vous dévoiler un secret
qui a été gracieusement enterré par l'histoire.
Lors de ma première conférence de presse,
un journaliste m'a demandé : « Madame Figueres,
pensez-vous qu'un accord mondial va être possible ? »
Et, sans que mon cerveau ne s'active, je me suis entendue dire :
« Jamais de la vie. »
Imaginez les visages de mon équipe de presse,
ils étaient horrifiés que cette folle Costaricienne
soit leur nouvelle patronne.
J'étais également horrifiée.
Ce n'était pas moi qui m'horrifiais, j'avais l'habitude.
J'étais horrifiée
par les conséquences de ce que je venais de dire,
les conséquences pour le monde
dans lequel nos enfants allaient devoir vivre.
C'était un moment vraiment horrible pour moi
et j'ai pensé : « Eh bien, non, attends, attends.
Impossible n'est pas un fait,
c'est un comportement. »
Ce n'est qu'un comportement.
J'ai alors décidé que j'allais changer mon comportement
et que j'allais aider le monde à changer son comportement
envers le changement climatique.
Alors, je ne sais pas --
Non, simplement ceci. Merci. --
Je ne sais pas
ce que vous feriez
si on vous disait que votre travail est de sauver la planète.
C'est dans la description du poste.
Vous avez l'entière responsabilité
et absolument aucune autorité
car les gouvernements sont souverains pour toutes les décisions qu'ils prennent.
J'aimerais vraiment savoir
ce que vous feriez le premier lundi matin,
mais voici ce que j'ai fait : j'ai paniqué.
(Rires)
Puis, j'ai paniqué à nouveau
car je n'avais aucune idée de comment résoudre ce problème.
Puis j'ai réalisé que je ne savais pas comment résoudre ce problème
mais je savais une chose :
nous devions changer le ton de la conversation.
Vous ne pouvez pas obtenir une victoire
sans optimisme.
Ici,
j'utilise le mot optimisme comme un mot très simple
mais comprenons-le dans son sens plus global.
Comprenons-le comme du courage,
de l'espoir, de la confiance, de la solidarité,
la croyance fondamentale que nous, humains, pouvons nous réunir
et nous entraider pour améliorer le sort de l'humanité.
Vous pouvez imaginez que je pensais que sans cela
nous ne sortirions jamais de la paralysie de Copenhague.
Pendant 6 ans,
j'ai obstinément, constamment, injecté de l'optimisme dans le système,
quelle que soit la question posée par la presse --
et je me suis améliorée pour cela --
et peu importe les preuves qui étaient contre moi.
Et, croyez-moi, il y a eu beaucoup de preuves contre moi.
Mais constamment injecter de l'optimisme dans le système.
Rapidement,
nous avons pu observer des changements dans de nombreux domaines,
précipités par des milliers de personnes,
y compris beaucoup d'entre vous,
et je vous remercie.
Cette communauté TED ne sera pas surprise
si je vous dit que le premier domaine
dans lequel j'ai observé un changement remarquable
était...
la technologie.
Nous avons commencé à voir que des technologies propres,
en particulier les technologies d'énergie renouvelable,
ont vu leur prix baisser et leur capacité augmenter
jusqu'au point où, aujourd'hui, nous construisons déjà
des centrales solaires
qui sont capables de fournir des villes entières en énergie,
pour ne rien dire sur ce que nous faisons concernant la mobilité
et les bâtiments intelligents.
Avec ce changement dans les technologies,
nous pouvons commencer à comprendre
qu'il y a un changement dans l'équation économique
car nous pouvons reconnaître
que oui, le changement climatique est extrêmement coûteux
et que certains risques sont accrus.
Mais il y a aussi des avantages économiques
et des intérêts intrinsèques
car la dissémination des technologies propres
nous apportera un air plus propre,
une meilleure santé,
de meilleurs moyens de transport, des villes plus vivables,
plus de sécurité énergétique,
plus d'accès à l'énergie dans les pays en développement.
En résumé, un meilleur monde que le monde actuel.
En comprenant cela,
vous devriez avoir observé, certains d'entre vous en font partie,
la propagation de l'ingénuité et de l'excitation
qui est passée, d'abord, par les organisations non nationales,
le secteur privé, les chefs d'entreprise, les compagnies d'assurances,
les investisseurs, les dirigeants municipaux,
les communautés de croyants,
car ils ont tous commencé à comprendre que cela était dans leur intérêt.
Cela peut améliorer leur fonctionnement fondamental.
Ce n'était pas seulement ceux auxquels on s'attendait.
Je dois vous dire que le PDG d'une très, très grande entreprise pétrolière
est venu me voir au début de l'année dernière
et a dit --
en privé, bien sûr --
qu'il ne savait pas comment il allait changer son entreprise
mais qu'il allait la changer
car il était intéressé par la viabilité à long terme.
Nous avons un changement dans l'équation économique
et, avec cela, plus de soutien de la part de tout le monde,
il n'a pas fallu longtemps avant que les gouvernements nationaux
comprennent que c'est dans l'intérêt national.
Quand nous demandions aux pays d'essayer d'identifier
comment ils pourraient contribuer aux efforts mondiaux
en se basant sur leur intérêt national,
189 pays sur 195,
189 pays ont envoyé leur projet complet sur le changement climatique
basé sur leurs intérêts nationaux
et leurs priorités,
en accord avec leurs projets nationaux de développement durable.
Eh bien,
si vous protégez les intérêts fondamentaux des nations,
vous comprenez que les nations sont prêtes
à essayer de converger vers un chemin commun,
dans une direction commune
qui nous prendra probablement plusieurs dizaines d'années
mais, au cours de ces années, ce chemin nous mènera
à une nouvelle économie,
à une économie décarbonisée et hautement résistante.
Les contributions nationales actuellement proposées
par les gouvernements nationaux
ne sont pas suffisantes pour que le climat se stabilise
mais c'est une première étape
et, avec le temps, cela s'améliorera.
La mesure, le compte-rendu et la vérification de ces efforts
sont des obligations légales.
Les contrôles que nous ferons tous les 5 ans
pour évaluer la progression collective vers notre objectif
sont des obligations légales.
Le chemin en lui-même vers une économie décarbonisée et plus résistante
est une obligation légale.
Et voici le plus important :
qu'avions-nous avant ?
A peine quelques pays
qui avaient adopté des engagements
très réduits et à court terme sur la réduction des émissions
qui étaient largement insuffisants
et, au-delà de cela, étaient perçus comme un fardeau.
Qu'avons-nous maintenant ?
Nous avons tous les pays du monde contribuant à différents degrés
selon différentes approches dans différents secteurs,
mais tous contribuent à un objectif commun
via un chemin
d'intégrité environnementale.
Une fois que tout cela a été mis en place
et que la compréhension a changé,
les gouvernements ont pu aller à Paris
et adopter l'accord de Paris.
(Applaudissements)
Donc,
quand je reviens
sur les six dernières années,
je me souviens d'abord
du jour où l'accord de Paris a été adopté.
Il y avait une telle euphorie dans la pièce.
5 000 personnes se levant de leur siège,
pleurant, applaudissant, criant, hurlant,
partagées entre euphorie et incrédulité face à ce qu'ils venaient de voir
car tant de personnes
ont travaillé des années pour cela et c'était finalement leur réalité.
Il n'y avait pas que ceux ayant directement participé.
Il y a quelques semaines, j'étais avec un collègue
qui essayait de décider
quelle perle tahitienne il voulait donner à sa merveilleuse femme Natasha.
Une fois qu'il a décidé ce qu'il voulait acheter,
le bijoutier lui a dit :
« Vous êtes très chanceux d'acheter cela maintenant
car, du fait du changement climatique,
ces pierres pourraient bientôt disparaître.
Mais, a dit le bijoutier, avez-vous entendu
que les gouvernements avaient trouvé un accord
et Tahiti pourrait avoir une chance ? »
C'était une fantastique confirmation
que peut-être, peut-être, il y a un espoir,
il y a une chance.
Je suis la première à reconnaître qu'il y a encore du travail.
Nous venons de commencer notre travail sur le changement climatique.
Nous devons nous assurer de redoubler d'effort
au cours des cinq prochaines années qui sont des années cruciales.
Mais je crois
que, les six dernières années, nous sommes passés
de l'impossible
à l’inarrêtable.
Comment avons-nous fait ? En injectant un optimisme transformationnel
qui nous a permis de passer de la confrontation à la collaboration,
qui nous a permis de comprendre que les intérêts nationaux et locaux
ne sont pas nécessairement opposés aux besoins mondiaux
et que, si nous comprenons cela, nous pouvons les réunir
et les combiner harmonieusement.
Alors que j'attends avec impatience d'autres problèmes mondiaux
qui demanderont notre attention pendant ce siècle --
la sécurité alimentaire, hydrique et intérieure, la migration forcée --
je ne sais pas encore
comment nous allons résoudre ces problèmes.
Mais nous pouvons tirer avantage de notre travail sur le changement climatique
et nous pouvons comprendre
qu'il nous fait réinterpréter la mentalité de la somme nulle.
Car on nous apprend à croire qu'il y a des gagnants et des perdants
et que votre perte est ma victoire.
Nous sommes maintenant dans un monde
où nous avons atteint les limites de la planète
et nous ne sommes pas seulement interconnectés
mais de plus en plus interdépendants les uns des autres,
votre perte n'est plus ma victoire.
Soit nous sommes tous perdants,
soit nous sommes tous gagnants.
Mais nous allons devoir décider
entre zéro et somme.
Nous allons devoir décider entre zéro bénéfice pour tous
ou vivre notre vie comme la somme de nous tous.
Nous l'avons fait une fois. Nous pouvons recommencer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)